hello I'm Mike comer the world champion
team manager of the st. Louis
Archbishop's alongside me is Grand
Master Geoffrey Zhang and believe it or
not the protest League st. Louis
Archbishop's and your career have some
similarities so obviously we got off to
a hot start we won the inaugural
championship in 2017 then we went to San
Francisco and played the Armenians and
all we got to show for it is this bronze
medal we lost to them but guess what we
persevered and we went right back there
in 2019 and illuminated them leaving
them with nothing but shattered dreams
and we got the gold medal now if you
look behind you Jeffrey you recognize
that so in 2015 you played in the US
Junior Championship and like the
Archbishop's the first time we play
Armenia we got so close to the victory
but lost by the narrowest of margins but
then that very next week you came back
played in us to st. Louis big tournament
and you got to revenge against the very
winner of the US Junior Champion Oxshott
Chandra and you became a grandmaster
after that so that's what we like in the
protest League the st. Louis
Archbishop's we like to persevere and
you're a heck of a winner and it is my
great honor for you to help continue the
dynasty and become an official member of
the st. Louis Archbishop's do you accept
absolutely awesome all right Jeffrey
stone looks good on you hopefully I will
win many more championships any Jeffrey
Jung will be playing as many games as he
desires he'll be playing alongside
Fabiano Wesley don't mean guess and we
weeklong so that's a heck of a lineup
huh
yeah yep I'm definitely really happy to
be part of st. Louis team they've
established a winning tradition and
hopefully I can be a good addition for
you guys we're banking on it and I'm
sure you're gonna do great season starts
January 2020 get your popcorn
[Music]
you